you know I started reading their
writings right and what I found out was
that the reason a lot of women advocated
for it was because they believed it was
the beginning of the breakdown of the
family you know before you became one in
marriage 85 percent of people were
married and you know I I hate to say it
but they were right what has happened
100 years later what's like what to do
with them having to vote well it also
goes back to responsibility
um
again men are 80 to 90 percent of the
military they run all of the
infrastructures that make Society run
so I just think if we want an equal say
in society then be equal do 50 of the
hard jobs be 50 of the military in the
US
um they're fine 250 000 if they are not
they don't join Selective Service which
is essentially the truth